l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj io sono arrivato al
punto in cui ho finito octo dead
ci sono delle cose che non hanno ancora
fatto non ho mai fatto anzi sono le
mappe workshop perché esiste il workshop
su supporto dell incredibile non
sapevano anch'io outlet island escape
occhio tendono a plane pour come sono
bellissime a vedersi e poi magari fai
cagare
[Musica]
ognuno dei talenti nella vita questo
credo sia il mio ragazzo ho scaricato un
po di livelli facciamo tipo quello che
ecco questo tipo breaking dawn of the
dead miley cyrus praticamente proviamo a
vedere che cosa esce fuori la sta roba
non prometto niente
no non ci credo non ci credo non ci
credo non ci credo
zitti voglio vedere la ragazza ho
bisogno
insomma
forse
ti prego no di subito
ma non c'è la palla a sono io eh no
vabbè quanto il ritardo è bellissimo a
sto male sia perché c'è miley che canta
in primo piano e va bene è la cosa più
sexy che abbiamo rivisto ma dove sono
ma non c'ero ma non ci
il mio canale non può scendere più di
due si fanno giugno quando mi contenuti
di qualità fa vj porta c'è lista ma cosa
volete di più
cosa va bene questi primi piani
bellissime che ha fatto quando è sceso è
capito poesia ragazzi poesia poesia
video lui di ma cosa volete
ma che cosa volete di più cosa volete
uncharted della stoffa asma che siete
scemi quando cioè sta roba qua
[Musica]
bellissimo bellissimo meraviglio poesia
o la pelle d'oca
che cosa ho visto nel mondo cosa
meravigliosa legame era bellissimo
veramente bello island skype let's go
bravo a scappare dall'isola
non ho mai fatto sta roba è una figata
assurda rompi 3 noci di cocco va bene
siofok todd ed posso andare nell'acqua
si sa posso stare nell'acqua dovrebbe
ovviamente sono un polipo sono forse sta
nel acqua io l'ha ancora fatta di
plastica perfetto a una noce di cocco
infatti è proprio nell'isola
ok come faccio a romperle cielo però non
ha ok lo schianta le per terra va bene
l'altra l'ho vista prima stava tipo qua
ammazza che non vorrei mai fare braccio
di ferro con te 86 veramente in gamba
sembri molle e poi sei duro devo
ricordarmi di tagliarla in editing sta
frase no questo è il rompi vile ok
perfetto poi mangia almeno no e cocco e
cocco rimane illumina dei flare che sono
i flirt poteva fare delle scale pelo più
easy di queste porco mondo c'è veramente
sta diventando il livello di getting
over it lega va bene scaliamo e getting
over it uva la montagna e la stessa
anche l'incazzatura la stessa
ve lo assicuro da fare delle scale
segundo normali no facciamo degli
scalini giganteschi va bene poggiati
poggiati poggiati da qualche parte bravo
zio tornado rai prima tornandovi prima
no no no no mi sono salvato per culo
bravissimo bravi bravissimo ma no non è
vero port col demonio morto ieri a me
sono questi flare a cagare e pensava
micheli sto facendo la montagna salva il
pesce ok che gioco simpatico che è
diventato l'ho salvato allora savall nel
senso te volevo votarlo nell'acqua è
stato un fallimento totale però
bene adesso ha funzionato clive to the
watchtower sapevo che sarebbe arrivato
questo momento lo sapevo devi salire
sulla watch tower che sarà questo
acquisto che il problema è che non
riesco a star no rega impossibile vero
giusta parte infatti vi la cala poi
bravissimo no mette il piedino di sopra
di sopra di sopra lo schifo ma come si
fa ma allora sentite questo potrebbe
essere un problema
gesù no no no no no no no no getting
over octo del parco demonizzato sono
comparse le scritte sos dal nulla
rega è impossibile che è impossibile
scalare sta roba è impossibile ti ci
vuole una pazienza oriente incredibile
faccio prima a prendere la laurea che i
no si perfetto ora fai piano fi pian
piano madonna piano che ambiente
t'ammazzo tutta la famiglia di polipi
piano ok mette un piede
minchia incredibile il camp nou non
cadere qua non cadere qua non cadere
quota ammazzo ti ammazzo ti ammazzo
faccio malissimo
ok no gesù
no ora non avete idea c'è seccato qua mi
ammazzo per ve lo giuro
grazie a dio c'è una nave in lontananza
spetta scusa c'è anche un drink qui
c'era per carità prendi siamo qui sono
youtuber mi salvi che devo caricare i
video sono salite wifi sulla nave vi
salvate e ho fatto segnale non vengono o
cacasotto qua no voleva sono orbi ma se
lo spara in alto esce tipo il simbolo di
batman solo alcuno di un polipo invece
che un pipistrello sono qua cosa devo
fare più che segnalare così scusa a s
o tua sorella no niente non va c'è una
sedia qui
venite è secondo me non hanno visto però
la serie è andata in mare effettivamente
è ancora lì una sedia che galleggia sono
riuscito ad avvisare di più con la sedia
che che con altro ragazzi non so come
avvisarli pericolosi ma scusami allora
porco mondo
venite venite c'è mica bilancio le robe
il tavolino il bicchiere tutto viaggio
gaga temi
come devo segnalare starship madonna di
dio scendi scendi capitoli bouton flare
non riesco piace ecco prima cadevo
sempre e adesso niente non un caso più
pesce vai ad avvisarli che sono qua c'è
dirglielo porca vacca morta
non è che devono votare filino no i nomi
nomi salirò tutto di nuovo sopra esso
non ha funzionato sono cavoli vostri no
rega mi rifiuto cioè vi giuro
categoricamente mi rifiuto sono ho vinto
ho vinto sono contento così basta c'è
veramente troviamo un altro livello
ragazzi sull'aereo non dentro l'aereo
sopra l'aereo va bene per andare in
cabina di pilotaggio et inside star
andando mica ai mille all'ora storico
permesso mi scusi non avevo il biglietto
per entrare mi sono occhio alla testa
che se per caso vi arriva un polipo in
faccia almeno sapete perché signori sono
qui pensa che che situazione strana per
dei piloti di aerei salve buongiorno
sono entrare per carità e non chiudete
le finestre però che che secondo me un
po di vento ci entra però possono
toccare questi tasti gliene frega
qualcosa bene join the mile high club
salve salve salve scusate mi ero facevo
parte dell'equipaggio poi c'è mia moglie
al cesso salve
ciao tesoro sono qua sta rifacendo le
tue cose qui cosa è successo ai finita
così amica era lunga come mappa della
prossima c'è il ma il club alla fine era
il cesso dove c'è la mia moglie ma
scusami questo è carino act hotel villa
amici posso buttare giù le macchine ei
grattacieli
no sarebbe fighissimo si potesse mettere
giù i grattacieli porca vacca ha poi
saluta trova per ciao ciao il livello
del mondo della vita dell'universo ciao
o o delle persone in mano permesso
salve scusate qua non ci sono obiettivi
da buttare giù le cose va bene posso
arrampicarmi di sopra vi prego ditemi se
non mi affaccio tipo king kong sul
grattacielo solo che sono un po lì poi
c'è qualche problema di fondo una banana
gigante chiarissimo ma comunque la gente
che fa sì livelli veramente
ma la data ci avete dei problemi
fatevelo dire ho fatto dei disastri sono
veramente ma come fate a passare che ci
sono i grattacieli in giro queste rob
dei mini pony beh giusto cosa perché
perché una città dovrebbe avere dei mini
pony al suo interno spiegami alle
macchine le macchie prendi le macchine
del monster dovrebbero farci un film su
un polipo gigante sarebbe un po trash
shark nato però un ananas apre in apple
e lei è già campione mondiale di lancio
dell'ananas va bè ragazzi ho fatto un
mezzo disastro
cell hamburgeria sembrava pari four
nights questa comunque quindi ragazzi
questa è la oxford ed questi erano i
livelli della gente io lo sapevo che
tanto sarebbe scesa in ignoranza la
faccenda molto più ignorante di quanto
pensassi però decisamente più ignorante
di quanto pensassi come se vi precisione
quanto mi piace anche la ricevente
descrizione se non siete a quelli cities
chiedetevi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
vedo bene grazie
[Musica]